the best treatment for indigestion? Well, indigestion is a word that encompasses a lot of symptoms.
So, a person has a lot of gas or a person gets constipation, or a person has diarrhea,
a person has tummy aches after they eat, a person has burping, bulging after they eat,
a person has heartburn. All these things can be called indigestion. So, we'd want to know a little
bit more information. But in general, most got issues, really start with an issue with most
commonly a decreased hydrochloric acid production of the stomach, which leads to a lot of stress
on the pancreas in production of enzymes. So, you know, the basic general best recommendation for
people with any tummy issues whatsoever is to start taking some HCl with digestive enzymes.
Now, you can get a person with such bad gut issues that they take HCl with digestive enzymes,
you only take those with your foods who take it with a meal. So, a person will say,
I did that and it really, I just caused really bad pain in my stomach. Well, then you got to kind of
take a step back and treat the gut because you probably have just a slight ulcer or some serious
irritation. Maybe you have to go to use some gut healing products like slippery elm. I'd have a whole
profile on this on our website. If you go to our website, cuttersclinic.com, you search hypochloridria.
Hypochloridria. Hypochloridria is low stomach acid. Okay, low hydrochloric acid in your stomach.
So, if you search that, I have a whole protocol. It kind of walks you through if you have really bad
pain, then switch, take go off of the HCl, try apple cider vinegar for a pitotide,
still have pain with that, then maybe try slippery elm. Well, it's a new product, but it's
really good called GI suit. It's really beneficial. Little kids can take that. It's the chocolate
favorite flavored tablet that you could just suck on because you want to heal the tract all the way
down, even the esophagus that will help heal the stomach and the esophagus. To a point where a few
weeks later, then you could start taking apple cider vinegar with your food and you could tolerate that,
and you're starting to do a little bit better, and now you could take HCl at that
distance, what's your food. Of course, there's also some other things that encompass
the digestion from diarrhea and constipation. And again, the next thing that happens after
HCl deficiency is what's called the vegan syndrome, or the vegan syndrome. There's really three levels
of that, where you have intestinal probability, and you can test for that, so that's the CYREX,
already, two tests. But short of that, just trying to heal the gut, trying to find, it sets food
sensitivity, trying to find the things that are causing players to try to settle that down,